Brian we did sit down with Red Rock
search and rescue today and they walked
us through exactly how these aeds work
when it comes to trying to save
someone's life
call 911
these pads come out
I'm gonna pull off
so I could get the adhesive there's a
little picture they go on like so
patients and we had continued doing CPR
touch patients now it says don't touch
patient the AED is looking for
ventricular fibrillation so that's
that's a shockable rhythm so people say
I'm afraid to use it I don't want to
accidentally shock somebody you can't it
only shocks unpfib so it's calling for a
shot it's not making sure nobody's
touching patient I'm clear you're clear
everybody clear
I'm just going to follow the directions
of the AED leave the pads on because as
time goes on approximately two minutes
it's going to keep looking for that
v-fib and tell me the shock again if it
detects v-fib
now he did also mention that when an AED
is used it increases a person's chance
of survival by about 38 now if you would
like to get CPR training he mentioned
that CPR is used in tandem with an AED
the American Red Cross the American
Heart Association do offer classes here
locally reporting live tonight saw the
Loftus 8 News Now